bake with me as I make some food to bring to my very pregnant friend
first thing I wanted to do is make some chicken pot pie
this is just really freezer friendly
the perfect thing to have postpartum
a quick homemade meal that you can just pop into the oven
and this is with a sourdough crust
and then I made some granola
this is not pregnancy related at all
it's just really fun to gift and also delicious
and I also got these cute bakery bags that I wanted to try as well
so once it cooled I just added in some chocolate and coconut flakes
it was so good and then I made two different kinds of muffins
firstly some orange cranberry ones
these were so fresh and delicious
and then also a classic banana chocolate chip and walnut muffin
this is with sourdough so it's fermented overnight
and then lastly I made some nut butter snack balls
I just thought this would be perfect for middle of the night
breastfeeding sessions and then I just put everything into a cute little basket
added some homemade labels
and I also included these cute little baby overalls
it just made me so happy and there you go
that is my basket of goodies
link below for all of the recipes and free labels